in an urgent push for diplomacy the
american president issued a stark
warning and a plea for peace to the
citizens of russia
you are not our enemy
and i do not believe you want a bloody
destructive war against ukraine
it came on a day of more mixed messages
from russia
the kremlin said it planned to pull back
some troops from border areas russia's
parliament requested vladimir putin
recognize russian-backed separatist
regions in ukraine
as independent states
and after a meeting with the german
chancellor putin made unsupported claims
of genocide in ukraine's donbass region
do we want war of course not he said so
far
we have not seen any sign of
de-escalation on the ground
true or not analysts see hopeful signs
in russia's claims of a modest troop
pullback i take it as a step back and i
take it as a hopeful sign again very
cautiously that he's prepared to step
away and negotiate some of the
issues
ukraine now surrounded on three sides by
150 000 russian troops sees less reason
for optimism an apparent cyber attack
hit several banks and government
websites tuesday
while back in washington the tone of the
american president suggested serious
concern that putin may not be talked
down let there be no doubt
if russia commits this breach by
invading ukraine
responsible nations around the world
will not hesitate to respond
tonight ukraine has made an emergency
request to nato for supplies to prepare
for what it calls large-scale crises
affecting its civilian population among
the items they're seeking demining
equipment explosives detection equipment
and medical supplies all ominous signs
of what may be to come
donna
jackson proskow in washington